pardon papa mon papa me panique a
notamment annoncé raté j'ai recommencé
bon attention 2 3 4 1 2 3 4
non c'est pas encore ça ah la la tian
bonjour j'ai tellement occupés à régler
un nouveau pas de danse que je ne vous
avais pas vus regardez je vais vous
montrer
je suis sûr que je vais le réussir cette
fois 2 3 4 c'était mieux et vous savez
un cetain et pas regardant ce qui fait
le plus rire
le facteur emile campagne j'adore fait
rire le facteur d'ailleurs j'aime faire
rire tout le monde
mais vous savez c'est pas toujours
facile pour trouver quelque chose comme
ça ou alors comme ça eh bien il ça
demande beaucoup de répétitions oui il
faut vraiment très beau aujourd'hui dans
l'île aux enfants
n'est ce pas j'ai envie de faire un jeu
vous êtes d'accord
ouais bon alors il y aura quoi est ce
que l'on pourrait bien jouer écouter on
va aller demander à françois deux
trottoirs aux verts grands soirs
quelquefois ça voilà que duncan décida
de faire un jeu avec tous nos amis qui
connaît toujours des tas de nouvelles
que tu nous elle est que tu viennes
jouer avec nous quasiment un bandit dont
j'ai bien cru que du tar et très jamais
4 et malheureusement n'ont quasi mis en
ondes
j'aimerais bien venir jouer avec vous
tous mais aujourd'hui j'ai vraiment un
travail fou du travail
évidemment j'ai reçu une commande
importante de ballons de monsieur du
snob qui organise une petite fête chez
lui alors il faut que je les gonfle que
je fixe les baguettes métalliques et je
suis pas prêt d'avoir fini en baisse et
du travail tout ça ben évidemment
le travail d'un marchand de ballons
cette gonfler ses ballons le mieux
possible pour qui se dégonfle pas et de
les vendre
bricmont alors je te laisse parce que le
travail c'est sacré tu as très bien
compris merci casimir mais dis donc si
je finis à tôt je viendrai jouer avec
vous à tout elle d'accord 1 à tout à
l'heure
rail bien papam attendent pas mon papa
julie fallu casimir et excuse moi mais
que j'ai je suis complètement débordé
annonce le bras quand tu viens jouer
avec moi et que nos amis qui attendent
on va faire un jeu un objet aurait bien
aimé c'est dommage mais c'est un travail
terrible du travail moi aussi et par oui
j'ai beaucoup de travail tu sais pour
que les enfants de l'île où les
visiteurs trouvent ce qu'ils veulent
dans le kiosque
il faut que je fasse des commandes on
fabricant de jouets aux usines de
bonbons et de limonade et puis après
pour donner aussitôt à ceux qui viennent
ceux qui le désirent
il faut que je range tout bien dans le
kiosque ça doit pas être facile surtout
que tu mélanges toujours les caramels et
les bonbons à la groseille
il faut avouer que je ne suis pas très
ordonnée mais à la fin je me retrouve
toujours c'est le principal
enfin sauf quand je te demande lougah
françois quand tu me donnes d'abord la
glace et quand le temps que tu trouves
les anchois la glace a fondu et coutts
elles se produit qu'une fois et je te
promets que ça ne se reproduira plus je
sais où tu as rangé les anchois
maintenant non mais je chercherai les
eaux froides à bord et je te donnerai la
glace ensuite bon tu es gentil hein tu
me laisse travailler parce que monsieur
du snob organise une fête
il m'a commandé pour ses invités les
petits paquets avec eux à caramel à
réglisse anuga une sucette et à bonbons
fourrés à la framboise
ça doit pas être facile bon ben alors je
te laisse
tout à l'heure qu'est ce que ça serait
pas bonjour facteur bouton est sable
bonjour j j terre est bien le chemin
pour venir jusqu'ici embaume le parfum
des fleurs
c'est vraiment très agréable de
travailler quand l'air est doux comme
aujourd'hui
vous travaillez vous aussi pour sûr mais
porter des lettres d'une personne à une
autre
ainsi que des colis tu sais c'est
vraiment un travail très important
ouais bon mais à l'aube bon courage ce
facteur merci à bien tourner un effet de
levier
olala c'est terrible tout le monde
travaille dans l'île aux enfants
il ya que moi qui ne fait rien et je ne
fais rien parce que parce que je ne sais
pas aulas qu'est ce que je vais devenir
or
je suis contente j'ai terminé mon
travail et moi aussi
il faut bien dire que rien ne procure
plus de joie quel travail bien fait on
pense à mon rang priest qu'est-ce qu'il
a désignés pour coup et tutrice
ces cinq ans françois viens de lire je
vois pas en quoi la joie que procure le
travail bien fait peta rendre triste
mais parce qu'en souvenir aux enfants
reçus le sens qu'ils ne travaillent pas
un qui trompe qui fait au contraire le
plus beau travail de toute l'île aux
offres
quoi qu'est ce que ça françois réseau au
travail c'est de faire rimer jouer et
qu'il fait très bien et tout à l'heure
c'est jeter admirer quand tu répétais
était pas de danse tu es formidable
alors quand je planque pour m'amuser
c'est du travail absolument julie tu as
le temps alors on va travailler pour les
yeux d'accord je les enfants 0
venez avec moi on va regarder julie et
casimir entraînements c'est d'accord
l'euro s'installe sur le dos voilà
premières loges ici
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
huawei
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pis
[Applaudissements]